- So I have to say. The Rock
was your last match, right?
So in the ring he actually
whispered something in your ear.
So what did he say?
- We're Wrestlemania 19 in Seattle
and there was probably a
70 to 75,000 people there
we sold it out, Rock and I headlined
through Wrestlemania together,
which no one has ever done.
And he knew that after that match
I was gonna retire and
ride off into the sunset.
And he knew that I didn't wanna retire,
but you know, I have some
nerve and neck issues
and I needed to get out of the business.
And after the three
count, after he pinned me,
after three rock bottoms, he just said,
"Man, I can't think enough
for what you did for me.
"I just want you to know, I love you man."
- Aww.
- And, and I'm laying there
and we got 70,000 people.
There's a couple of
million people watching
on pay-per-view and you know,
I just kinda looked up at him, I said,
I think I had my eyes closed, I said,
"I love you, too."
Verbatim.
And it's been a deal where, you know,
Rock and I have been great friends
from when he first came into the company
and we turned it into a rivalry.
And at many times, you know,
when he was the bad guy
or I was the bad guy, and
when we were both good guys,
we always had a great friendship
and a lot of respect and a
lot of love for each other.
And the thing about The Rock was
he was one of, probably
my most favorite opponent.
He brought out the best in me
and I brought out the best in him.
And when you put the two number one guys
in there together, magic happens.
- Yeah I love, I love
when chemistry happens
like that, like in any kind of form
when people are working together.
It's just like if it's in a TV show
or in WWE, or if it's in a movie,
whatever it is, or musically
speaking, it's so cool.
And that you feel it, you
feel that kind of energy.